Remember that these are the times we really
need independent media.
I would invite you to grab a membership at
Join Pakman Dotcom.
The prices are reasonable.
The company is friendly and you really are
doing a lot to support our work when you sign
up.
Donald Trump, exactly as predicted, held an
event that was almost like a rally at the
White House last night, something like 2:00
in the morning, East Coast time.
And Donald Trump says he won.
Donald Trump claims he won the presidency.
Donald Trump claims he won states that he
did not actually win.
And Trump says that they're trying to steal
it from him.
They being, I guess, Democrats.
You have to see this.
This is red alert stuff.
This is the stuff of dictators.
This is the stuff of dystopian authoritarians.
This is the exact situation about which I
warned you.
Donald Trump and his family coming into cheers
at the White House like this is a victory
rally, literally, as Trump's lead in Wisconsin
was evaporating and switching to Biden as
Trump's lead in Michigan was evaporating and
switching to Biden.
The election results still in question with
multiple paths to victory as of this moment
for Joe Biden doesn't mean Biden will win,
but this was not a time to declare victory.
So in comes Donald Trump.
Thanks, people as if he's won and says there
is an attempt to disenfranchize his supporters,
of course, asserting this without evidence.
I want to thank the American people for their
tremendous support.
Millions and millions of people voted for
us tonight and a very sad group of people
is trying to disenfranchize that group of
people.
And we won't stand for it.
We will not stand.
There is no evidence that anyone is trying
to disenfranchize Trump voters, and in fact,
there is evidence of the opposite from this
Trump event, which we will get to.
Trump comes out and says they're trying to
disenfranchize my voters later.
Trump confirms he's trying to disenfranchize
Biden voters.
And we will get that.
Trump, as one example, is trying to disenfranchize
by claiming he won states that haven't yet
been called.
Trump claims he won Georgia.
As I showed you in our earlier segment, Georgia
is still counting ballots.
It is, according to the numbers, leaning Trump,
although the New York Times has an indicator
that says it may once Atlanta has counted
Joe Biden.
The point is he had not won Georgia.
At this point in time, there's never been
anything like it to support our incredible
movement.
We won states that we weren't expected to
win Florida.
We didn't win, and we wanted by a lot.
We won the great state of Ohio, we won Texas,
we won.
We won Texas by 700000 votes and they don't
even include it in the tabulations.
It's also clear that we have won Georgia.
We're up by 2.5 percent or one hundred and
seventeen thousand votes with only seven percent
left and never going to catch us, they can't
catch us.
Trump may win Georgia in the end, but to claim
at two a.m. last night as counting in Atlanta
had stopped, that he had one is wrong.
And when he talks about suppression, that
is a way to suppress activism by saying I
already won it.
Don't even worry about pushing for the votes
to be counted.
We have to see what happens when Atlanta ballots
are counted.
This is Trump assuming a victory that he didn't
have and certainly didn't have last night.
We will see if he ever gets it.
How things change so quickly, though, because
Donald Trump came out and said at the same
event, there's a good possibility that I'll
win Arizona.
Biden's margin has grown in Arizona.
Trump touted a lead in Michigan, which has
flipped now to Joe Biden.
Trump said he was winning Wisconsin.
Wisconsin has flipped to Joe Biden razor thin
margins, but they have flipped.
Now, understand this.
When Donald Trump came out last night, he
was losing Arizona, but he was ahead in Pennsylvania.
There are far more ballots left to be counted
in Pennsylvania than there are in Arizona.
But Trump comes out and says we need to keep
counting in Arizona.
But he says nothing about counting ballots
in Pennsylvania with far more outstanding
ballots, in particular from Philadelphia,
Pittsburgh and other Democratic leaning areas.
Take a look at this.
We also if you look and you see Arizona, we
have a lot of life in that.
And somebody said somebody declared that it
was a victory for us and maybe it will be.
I mean, that's possible.
But certainly there were a lot of votes out
there that we could get because we're now
just coming into what they call Trump territory.
I don't know what you call it, but these were
friendly Trump voters and that could be overturned.
The gentleman that called and I watched tonight,
he said, well, we think it's fairly unlikely
that he could catch Will.
Fairly unlikely.
And we don't even need it.
We don't need that.
That was just a state that if we would have
got it, it would have been nice, Arizona.
But there's a possibility, maybe even a good
possibility.
In fact, since I saw that originally has been
changed and the numbers have substantially
come down just in a small amount of votes.
So we want that obviously to stay in play.
But most importantly, we're winning Pennsylvania
by a tremendous amount of.
We're up six hundred, think of this, think
of this.
Think of this.
We're up 600 and 90000 votes in Pennsylvania,
600000.
These aren't even close.
It's not like, oh, it's close.
With 64 percent of the vote in, it's going
to be almost impossible to catch.
And we're coming into good Pennsylvania areas
where they happen to like your president and
lots of votes to get in Arizona.
They must keep counting.
And we're winning Pennsylvania.
But only 60 percent has been counted.
Says nothing about continuing to count in
Pennsylvania.
And as we told you, Pennsylvania is a key
state where suppressing the count, suppressing
the mail in ballots is their stated strategy.
It's not we think they might come up with
the it's their stated strategy.
And it's because Pittsburgh, Philly and some
other areas that are going big to Biden stopped
counting absentee ballots overnight.
They are resuming today.
That will hurt Trump.
So Trump says nothing about counting but Arizona.
He wants the vote to keep being counted here.
Trump says counting the votes is a conspiracy
against him.
I wish I had more explanation.
It's completely unintelligible.
And you take all of the others.
I mean, we have we have so many.
We had such a big night.
You just take a look at all of these states
that we've won tonight, and then you take
a look at the kind of margins that we've won
or by.
And all of a sudden, it's not like we're up
12 votes and we have 60 percent left.
We won states and all of a sudden I said,
what happened to the election?
It's off.
And we have all these announcers saying, what
happened?
And then they said, oh, because you know what
They knew they couldn't win.
So they said, let's go to court.
And did I predict this Newt?
Did I say this?
I've been saying this from the day I heard
they were going to send out tens of millions
of ballots.
I said, exactly.
It's, of course, been Trump who has been threatening
to go to court.
I have no idea what he's talking about.
It's incoherent.
It doesn't make any sense.
And then Donald Trump goes totally in as he
reads vote numbers into the a fraud has been
committed approach, says definitively, we
did win this election.
Remember, he didn't win yet.
He certainly hadn't won last night.
He hasn't won as of right now.
And then Donald Trump starts to allude to
going to the Supreme Court to help him by
stopping ballot counts.
He's doing everything we predicted.
So we won there.
We lead by 76000 votes with almost nothing
left.
And all of a sudden everything just stopped.
This is a fraud on the American public.
This is an embarrassment to our country.
We were getting ready to win this election.
Frankly, we did win this election.
So our goal now is to ensure the integrity
for the good of this nation.
This is a very big moment.
This is a major fraud in our nation.
We want the law to be used in a proper manner.
So we'll be going to the U.S. Supreme Court.
We want all voting to stop.
We don't want them to find any ballots at
four o'clock in the morning and add them to
the list.
OK, it's that's very sad.
It's a very sad moment to me.
This is a very sad moment and we will win
this.
And as far as I'm concerned, we already have
won it.
So I just want to thank a major fraud.
We won.
We will be going to the Supreme Court, a major
fraud.
There's no evidence of unless the fraud was
perpetrated by him.
And he knows something.
He's not telling us we won.
Not at that point and not at this time.
We will be going to the Supreme Court maybe.
And that could be a disaster.
He's telling us the strategy.
He's saying he wants the voting to stop voting
has stopped.
What needs to happen is the counting.
He wants you to believe people are still voting,
nobody still voting.
Any ballots submitted at this point would
not be valid, valid.
But the ballots that have been submitted and
not delivered yet must be counted.
He's done everything it looked like he would
do.
He has.
I did a segment Monday.
Trump will step up to a podium and claim victory
when there's no victory to claim he did it.
Some of you wrote to me, said, David, you're
being hyperbolic.
He did it.
He's alleging fraud by the other side when
there's no evidence of such fraud.
He did it.
He's saying that he will go to the courts,
including the Supreme Court.
That's exactly what we predicted.
Will he get away with it?
Is the question we now have to ask.
The next 24 to 72 hours will
be crucial.